Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Sono qui per parlarvi un po'
delle connessioni quantistiche.
Perché "connessioni al cubo"?
Beh, quello che stiamo facendo adesso
è utilizzare, anche se magari
non vi sembra, la tecnologia quantistica.
Perché solo conoscendo
le leggi della meccanica quantistica
possiamo avere un laser
che mi permette di puntare qui sopra,
possiamo avere un calcolatore,
dei transistor, dei processori e così via.
Però, la storia che vi voglio raccontare
è quella della "Seconda
Rivoluzione Quantistica".
Perché oggi, quello che noi abbiamo
nei nostri bit,
nella nostra società digitale,
i bit sono zeri e uni,
accendo e spengo dei circuiti,
sono elettroni che vanno e vengono,
sono fotoni che stanno
in una fibra ottica, e che si muovono.
Cos'è la seconda rivoluzione quantistica?
Per raccontarvelo,
voglio partire da una cosa
che mi è successa ormai 20 anni fa,
quando la mia prima settimana,
finito il dottorato,
il mio primo lavoro
all'Università di Innsbruck,
prendo la bici, esco dalla cantina,
mi viene incontro una limousine nera.
Esce il Dalai Lama, che è qui.
E lui era venuto in cantina -
non c'era solo la bici,
ma c'erano anche i laboratori
del mio collega Rainer Blatt.
E lì, Sua Santità ha potuto fare una cosa
che a lui, a scuola -
a tutti noi a scuola,
e anche a mio figlio recentemente -
è stato insegnato che non è possibile:
ci è stato, a tutti, detto:
non è possibile vedere un singolo atomo.
Allora ti dicono: sì, c'è
il microscopio elettronico,
forse puoi avere
una cosa indiretta, eccetera,
anche quel buco nero dell'altro ieri
non è veramente una foto,
ma è una cosa ricostruita;
ma all'atomo non puoi fare la foto,
non lo vedi con gli occhi.
Allora, nel laboratorio del mio collega,
c'è una piccola trappola.
Vuol dire che sono
degli elettrodi di metallo, insomma,
dentro uno scatolotto vuoto
con un vetro sopra.
E tra lo scatolotto e il mio occhio
c'è un microscopio,
ci sono solo delle lenti.
E io aspetto alcuni minuti,
e così ha fatto anche Sua Santità.
Dopo tre, quattro minuti,
si abitua l'occhio al buio.
Appoggio l'occhio sull'oculare,
e dentro lo vedo.
Un piccolo atomino verdolino:
tutto solo, in mezzo al buio,
e però io lo vedo, direttamente.
Quello che i padri fondatori
della meccanica quantistica
pensavano fosse impossibile -
dicevano: più facile che fare
un esperimento con un singolo atomo
è allevare un dinosauro in uno zoo,
come dire che non succederà mai -
succede oggi, succede tutti i giorni,
succede in una montagna
di laboratori in giro per il mondo,
in giro per l'Europa
e anche in giro per l'Italia.
L'Italia è anche molto avanti,
su questo campo di ricerca.
E questo per me è il punto di partenza
perché, in qualche modo,
costruire questo atomino è una cosa
che è fondamentalmente inutile:
è solo per la meraviglia,
solo per essere affascinante se si vuole;
ma questo è la base,
è il fondamento su cui si sviluppano
tutta una serie di cose
che vanno molto in là,
e questo è quello che vorrei raccontarvi.
Un passo indietro: ho parlato, prima,
della tecnologia digitale di oggi.
Questo è il primo transistor
che è stato costruito nel '47,
era una cosa grande così;
poi è stato miniaturizzato,
miniaturizzato, miniaturizzato;
oggi abbiamo milioni
e miliardi di transistor
su ciascuno dei chip
che ci portiamo dietro in tasca,
nei nostri telefoni e così via.
La legge di Moore è stata formulata
più di 50 anni fa, e dice:
ogni paio d'anni riusciamo
a mettercene il doppio,
di questi piccoli elementi
per i circuiti digitali,
sullo stesso spazio.
E ci costa sempre uguale.
E quindi abbiamo computer
sempre più potenti, sempre più potenti.
E questo lo vediamo qui, ad esempio:
il numero di transistor che ci sono
a seconda del tempo
è cresciuto enormemente,
da un migliaio a 20 miliardi,
questo è quello che vi portate
tutti quanti in tasca.
E però, adesso, questa cosa sta finendo.
Questa è, di fatto, la base
per tutte le tecnologie che utilizziamo,
per tutti i nostri social media.
I vostri social media, facebook e twitter,
senza la meccanica quantistica
non sarebbero possibili.
Ora, si può discutere
se sarebbe una cosa positiva
o negativa, naturalmente;
ma comunque questo ci indica chiaramente
che ha un impatto molto importante
su quello che noi facciamo.
Ma adesso, andare molto in là
non è possibile,
perché se lo rendo sempre più piccolo
alla fine arrivo all'atomo;
e l'atomo è "ciò che non si può tagliare a
metà" più piccolo dell'atomo è impossibile
È un quanto. Più piccolo non c'è.
Allora, cosa vuol dire?
Che quando facciamo
le cose sempre più piccole,
raggiungiamo un limite:
questa crescita enorme, a un certo punto,
si romperà e si interromperà.
E noi possiamo o disperarci,
oppure, come se fossimo
una grande industria di computer,
oppure come alcune
grandi industrie di computer
come Microsoft, IBM, Intel, Google
che stanno investendo centinaia
di milioni, ciascuna, ogni anno -
e tra alcune settimane ci sarà
un annuncio molto importante
da parte di Google, in questo senso -
dicono: vabbè, è caduta,
non c'è più questa crescita enorme,
inventiamoci qualcosa di nuovo.
Questo è uno stimolo
per l'innovazione futura.
E questa è l'idea
delle tecnologie quantistiche.
Allora, qui passiamo
dalle connessioni alla prima potenza -
quelle normali, di tutti i giorni:
facebook, Internet -
alle connessioni alla seconda.
E "connessioni da paura"
è una cosa che aveva detto Einstein.
Einstein non credeva
che la meccanica quantistica fosse giusta,
lui era convintissimo che fosse sbagliata
e ha detto: adesso io vi dimostro
che non può altro che essere sbagliata.
Perché prevede queste connessioni assurde,
"connessioni da paura"
lui aveva proprio detto;
e qui c'è un disegnino.
Naturalmente non vi faccio le formule,
ma la differenza non è tantissima.
Qui ho un disegnino
di un piccolo sistema quantistico,
come quell'atomino di prima.
In qualche modo dentro,
come in questo disegno di un cubo,
c'è sia la figura, la possibilità
del cubo con la faccia in su
che la possibilità del cubo
con la faccia in giù.
Ci sono tutte e due.
Quando provate a guardarlo,
non siete in grado di vederlo,
nello stesso momento,
da una parte e dall'altra.
In qualche modo, fa clic avanti e
indietro o vi si stabilizza da una parte,
poi dovete pensarci:
forse c'è anche dall'altra.
Quando lo guardate, "cade"
in una delle due possibilità.
Se io ne ho più di uno di questi,
questa è una figura presa in prestito
da un collega Premio Nobel
nel 1997, Bill Phillips -
quello che succede, in questi due,
anche lì ci sono le due possibilità,
e quando li guardo anche lì collassano:
ora faccia in giù, ora faccia in su.
Ma il trucco, qui,
è che non conosco nessuno -
provate questo esercizio -
che riesca a vederli uno in giù
e uno in su nello stesso tempo:
o li vedete tutti e due in giù,
o tutti e due in su.
Einstein diceva: è assurdo questo,
perché nella meccanica quantistica
posso preparare degli stati così che,
se io poi questi due cubetti,
questi due elettroni, li separo,
loro sono sempre connessi.
E anche se ho un elettrone qui,
e l'altro è su Alpha Centauri,
io subito ne guardo uno,
e so immediatamente
che cosa succederà lassù
quando il mio collega lo va a controllare.
Istantaneamente.
E questa è una cosa che serve
per fare il teletrasporto.
E questa può sembrare una barzelletta.
E io vi posso dire che,
perché avete sentito sicuramente
che c'è il teletrasporto su "Star Trek",
e io vi posso dire tranquillamente
che nessuna persona
verrà teletrasportata su "Star Trek"
perché per essere trasportati
bisogna essere raffreddati molto,
tipo verso lo zero assoluto,
quindi non è facile ricordarsene
dopo che è successo;
ma comunque -
vi posso dire che quello di "Star Trek"
è molto più noioso
di quello vero, quantistico,
perché in Star Trek quello che succede
è "Beam me up, Scottie",
che significa: trasmetti me,
io so che cosa viene trasmesso,
e so dove viene trasmesso;
ma nel teletrasporto quantistico
non ha nessuna importanza
dov'è andato a finire
quest'altro elettrone o fotone:
potrebbe essere su Alpha Centauri,
potrebbe essere a Milano Lambrate,
potrebbe essere dove volete voi,
e comunque questa cosa funziona.
E viene trasportato un messaggio segreto,
uno stato non conosciuto -
perché non posso sapere qual è
prima di averlo misurato -
e viene trasportato
in un posto che non conosciamo.
E questo, ancora una volta,
sembra una cosa inutile,
magari fantasiosa, ma non tanto realistica
e magari neanche tanto pratica;
e invece, quello che possiamo fare -
e qui arriviamo alle connessioni al cubo,
il terzo strato, il terzo livello -
è quello nel quale possiamo utilizzare
queste cose come tecnologia.
Partono da chiedersi,
come ha fatto Einstein
in maniera completamente filosofica,
se la realtà esiste o non esiste:
ad esempio, ci sono stati
esperimenti, fatti da colleghi,
che hanno realizzato
questa cosa di Einstein
chiedendosi se la realtà
esiste localmente.
La risposta è: la realtà,
localmente, non esiste.
Ora non abbiamo tempo,
serve un altro talk
per per raccontare questa cosa,
ma quello che interessa qui
è che possiamo usare queste cose.
Perché?
Perché se io il mio stato lo uso
per trasmettere un messaggio,
e se questo messaggio,
che può essere Zero o Uno,
può essere un bit di una lunga stringa
di un messaggio che voglio trasmettere,
se questo messaggio, questo dato
non c'è prima che io lo misuri,
allora non può essere
intercettato da nessuno,
semplicemente perché non c'è.
Lo stato, la lettera, lo zero o l'uno,
appare solo dopo che io ho fatto
quella misura di prima.
E questo sembra una cosa fantascientifica,
e invece ci sono ditte che vi vendono
dispositivi che fanno queste cose.
C'è una ditta, a Ginevra,
che è leader mondiale di questi temi,
si chiama AdQuantic.
E non sto facendo pubblicità
a quella ditta:
sto dicendo che qui, in Europa,
siamo riusciti, partendo da queste idee
fondamentali, basilari,
a sviluppare delle tecnologie
che adesso veramente hanno la supremazia
in giro per il mondo.
E a Vienna il collega Zeilinger
è riuscito a fare, per la
prima volta, il teletrasporto.
Lo stato a cui siamo adesso
è che è possibile
comprare questi dispositivi,
che banche e governi stanno comprando
per realizzare comunicazioni sicure:
vi mando un fotone,
nessuno può intercettarlo
perché se lo intercetta
lo rovina, lo distrugge;
se qualcuno ci ha provato
ci accorgiamo che ha provato a misurarlo,
e quindi se verifichiamo
che nessuno ha intercettato
abbiamo una comunicazione sicura
che protegge i vostri dati,
che protegge la vostra carta
di credito su Internet,
che protegge i dati sensibili
medici, e così via.
E questa è una cosa che adesso succede
su una distanza di alcune
centinaia di chilometri,
e i colleghi che,
per la prima volta, hanno fatto -
questa è una figurina di fantasia
di una decina di anni fa -
hanno realizzato questo per la prima volta
si sono accorti che magari
si poteva mandarlo sul satellite,
e hanno provato a proporlo
all'Agenzia Spaziale Europea,
la quale, nei successivi dieci anni,
ci ha dormito sopra.
E nel frattempo,
il primo autore del lavoro
che ha fatto questo,
che ha proposto questa idea -
si chiama Jian-Wei Pan:
non è esattamente tirolese,
come potete immaginare -
Lui è tornato a Shanghai,
e dal presidente Xi ha ricevuto
due miliardi di dollari
che gli hanno permesso
di realizzare questa cosa qui,
che è un satellite cinese
che in questo momento è in orbita
e con il quale sono già state fatte
delle videochiamate quantistiche sicure
a migliaia di chilometri di distanza
tra la Cina e l'Austria.
E questa è una conseguenza
del prendere queste particelle,
singole, strane, inaspettate,
con questi comportamenti
che non sono normali,
e utilizzarle per farci
qualcosa di tecnologico.
E questo è un esempio.
E adesso un altro esempio,
che coinvolge Milano, qui vicino a noi.
Non lo vediamo ancora,
ma se io uso un fotone
e lo spedisco sulla fibra ottica,
possiamo comunicare delle informazioni;
se invece uso degli atomi,
posso usarli per elaborare
delle informazioni.
Al posto di un transistor prendo un atomo,
quindi come ho detto
lo faccio sempre più piccolo,
arrivando al singolo atomo.
Lui si comporta, anche lui, l'atomo,
in questo modo strano quantistico.
Se ne ho tanti, di questi atomi,
loro sono nello stesso momento
in tutti i possibili stati,
tutte le possibili combinazioni.
Quindi, se io ho un computer quantistico
che riesce a manipolarli -
mantenendoli belli freddi,
come abbiamo detto prima -
quello che posso fare è:
ho un certo problema,
pongo una domanda al mio computer,
ma invece di porre una domanda alla volta
e ogni volta ottenere la risposta,
io posso scrivere in questo
computer quantistico, contemporanamente,
tutte le domande possibili,
e ottenere tutte le risposte
nello stesso momento.
È come cercare in un labirinto.
Invece di andare: provo qui;
dopo provo lì; dopo provo là,
andare nello stesso tempo in tutti
i possibili cammini del labirinto,
e voi capite che in un giro solo
io arrivo alla soluzione.
E questa è una potenza di calcolo enorme,
che può servire per l'ottimizzazione.
La Volkswagen ha usato
un simulatore quantistico
per ottimizzare il traffico
dei taxi a Pechino:
e questo, come ripeto spesso,
è una cosa che a un fisico, quale sono io,
non verrebbe in mente
neanche sotto l'effetto
di un influsso molto imponente di vodka,
perché è come dire - il fisico
non sta a pensare queste cose,
noi pensiamo ai nostri giochini,
ai nostri atomini eccetera;
però poi viene gente che dice:
ah, aspetta che si può fare
qualcosa di utile.
Due settimane fa mi ha chiamato Adidas
per sapere che cosa si può fare
con un simulatore quantistico
ci torno tra un attimo.
Allora, qui c'è un chip della Intel,
con sette, 17, 49 bit quantistici
che lo hanno presentato
alla fiera dell'elettronica
di Las Vegas l'anno scorso.
Quest'anno, la IBM ha presentato
il primo calcolatore
quantistico commerciale,
potete comprarvelo.
È stato fatto a Milano,
in modo che fosse abbastanza elegante
non è uno scherzo, la cosa esterna
è stata realizzata a Milano,
in modo che avesse un impatto visivo,
e quindi penso che anche qui a Busto
possiamo essere orgogliosi di questo -
ma quello che è rilevante
è che queste cose
stanno entrando nella realtà.
Dieci anni fa, quando ho cominciato
a insegnare queste cose,
dicevo agli studenti: sì, forse,
magari un giorno, ma insomma, boh;
e invece, oggi, ci sono.
Questo è forse, per me,
la cosa più incredibile di tutte.
Ho altre due trasparenze
che vi voglio mostrare,
su altre due possibilità.
Una è la simulazione quantistica:
uso appunto questi atomini singoli,
li metto in una struttura regolare,
come un cartone di uova, uno a uno,
e riesco a riprodurre
il comportamento di nuovi materiali,
magari uno dei composti chimici,
li posso utilizzare per sviluppare
dei nuovi sistemi chimici
da nuove sostanze,
magari di sostanze superconduttive
ad alta temperatura
con cui potrei fare delle linee elettriche
che non disperdano elettricità,
e quindi subito avrei, gratis,
il 50 percento in più di elettricità;
e invece, un altro esempio è:
se io utilizzo dei singoli elettroni,
li posso usare come sensori,
posso mettere un singolo elettrone
vicino a un neurone,
e si accorge se il singolo neurone
si è acceso o si è spento, in tempo reale.
La Bosch, in Germania,
sta creando un progetto pilota
per mettere sensori di questo tipo
su un casco che dovrebbe aiutarci
a leggere l'attività cerebrale
per, ad esempio, guidare un computer;
oppure, persone che non possono comunicare
per problemi neurologici
possono riuscire
a comunicare con l'esterno;
per le diagnosi, per la medicina;
c'è una montagna
di applicazioni possibili.
E questi sono i motivi
per cui la Commissione Europea
ha deciso di mettere i piedi
in questo programma molto grosso
di cui stavamo parlando prima.
E se ne sta aggiungendo un altro,
ne stiamo discutendo
proprio in questi giorni,
per creare una rete sicura
di comunicazione a livello europeo,
quindi un altro miliardo di euro
proprio per questo,
e per la protezione dei dati di tutti noi.
C'è un grande numero
di ricercatori coinvolti:
i dettagli non sono importanti,
quello che è importante
è che non solo c'è una connessione
tra questi quattro campi
che vi ho fatto vedere prima -
la comunicazione, la simulazione,
la computazione e la sensoristica -
ma che tutto quanto si appoggia
su una fondamentale scienza di base.
Perché queste cose sono possibili,
su questo torno tra poco,
soltanto se continuiamo a chiederci,
a porci le domande fondamentali,
quelle che sembrano completamente inutili.
E l'idea, l'obiettivo,
la speranza che abbiamo
è di poter arrivare
in qualche modo, come una missione,
di portare l'uomo sulla luna:
ma qui vedete, appunto, una bandiera,
come abbiamo visto un attimo fa,
di altri continenti
che sono molto avanti su questo tema.
E magari, la nostra speranza
è di poter sostituire quelle bandiere,
o accompagnarle con una bandiera nostra.
Io so che l'Unione Europea
non è sempre percepita
come la cosa più vicina ai cittadini;
ma questo è sicuramente un esempio
in cui l'Unione Europea
può fare davvero, qualcosa di forte
per tutti noi, per il futuro
delle nuove generazioni,
perché, appunto,
le fondamenta di questa cosa
vanno esattamente in questa direzione.
Il futuro, il futuro anche professionale,
non solo di servizi
e di possibilità tecnologiche
ma anche di posti di lavoro
per le nuove generazioni.
E questo mi permette di arrivare,
di nuovo, al fondamento delle cose.
Questa è una slide
che potrebbe sembrare stucchevole,
invece l'ho messa su,
ho concluso la mia presentazione
davanti a una dozzina di ministri
dell'Unione Europea, alcuni mesi fa.
Ho affittato la Hoffburg di Vienna-
il palazzo imperiale di Vienna,
non vi dico il costo
per fare la giornata iniziale
di questi progetti
che abbiamo appena cominciato.
E la mia slide finale era questa:
ricostruire una flagship,
una nave ammiraglia.
E il punto fondamentale,
forse l'unica cosa
che mi piacerebbe che ciascuno di voi
si portasse a casa oggi, è questa.
E questo ci collega, appunto,
con le nuove generazioni
ed è qualche cosa
che possiamo fare tutti noi,
possiamo imparare da loro
nel seguente senso:
che non importa quanto una cosa
sembra complicata, misteriosa, esoterica:
non importa neanche
quanto una cosa sembra utile.
Quello che importa, se vogliamo avere
non solo l'innovazione di domani
ma anche quella del giorno dopo,
e delle generazioni dopo,
è di non smettere mai
di guardare la realtà
con curiosità, con meraviglia.
Lasciandoci sorprendere,
lasciandosi affascinare.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)